Why is Donald Trump's so interested in
punishing the Islamic Republic of Iran?
If you've seen the previous two videos
in this series,
you might believe that he's interested
in raising all prices,
helping us Saudi friends.
I'll just showing the European Union
who's boss.
But here's another hypothesis.
What if Donald Trump is actually going
after the end of authoritarian rule in
Iran?
This is not a stupid theory.
Iran is that the edge of economic
collapse and to government protests,
uh,
frequented.
Unlike other countries in the regions in
Iran,
Dunn's have a secular,
liberal and democratic.
Okay?
This means
you don't need to wage real war to bring
democracy to this country choking regime
financially,
you know,
it actually works.
Donald trump could even be looking at a
Nobel peace prize.
Not only that,
it would make Obama look dumb and trump
would win the 20,
20 election for sure,
but what if it doesn't turn out as well
as he plans?
What if the ayatollah's regime is not as
weak as he thinks?
Can Trump win the bat?
Well,
there's video.
It covers all of that.
Iran is the man.
America loves to hate,
of course,
the White House claims that the nuclear
sanctions are not meant to topple the
regime,
but is that really true?
House national security advisor,
John Bowlby says,
the United States is not seeking to
topple Iran's government,
but since Washington does want
authorities in Tehran to change their
behavior,
but truth is for decades,
America has been trying to do everything
possible to curb the Iot has power.
For example,
have you ever heard of Radio Free
Europe?
During the Cold War,
the American Congress created this radio
station to spread anticommunist messages
into the Soviet Union.
Today this radio is still exists.
Indeed they have their offices very
close to where I am recording this video
in Prague,
in the Czech Republic,
and guess what?
This radio has a whole department just
defaulted to Iran.
They broadcast and using the Farsi
language to spread anti ayatollah
messages in signing the contract.
Does
this mean this means that Washington is
most definitely interested in a regime
change in Tehran,
but once you get really badly is one
thing,
whether it's actually possible is quite
another.
So the question that might be in your
mind right now is,
is Iran really that bad of a
dictatorship?
I mean,
at the end of the day,
they've got elections,
they've got political parties,
right?
Well,
yes and no.
Yeah,
it is true,
but Iranians can vote for the president,
but the actual person in charge is the
supreme leader.
Ayatollah Khomeini for better
understanding how many shoes is most of
the ministers and has the ultimate word
on international affairs and many of the
important,
oh,
and of course it goes without saying.
The political dissidence I'll absolutely
prosecuted and often killed by the
government.
In fact,
despite having some opposition
movements,
there are almost no important leaders.
Why?
Well,
that's because they're all dead in
prison or exiled.
Know what happens with the pro system,
but physical forces,
well rather than political parties,
we should
talk about the different factions.
One Hand.
We have the so called hardliners,
hardliners,
support the system created by Khomeini
to the letter religious law and state
led economy.
We have the reformers want to change the
regime from the inside.
As you can imagine,
this faction is losing power nowadays.
Finally,
we have the pragmatist,
who's most important representative
would be the current president,
Hassan Rouhani,
pragmatist lie,
somewhere in between the hardliners and
the reformers.
They want some economic reforms,
better relations with the West,
but also want to retain religious
control over the political system.
And here we have the second question.
Is it really possible for this whole
political system to fall apart?
Well,
there is a chance you see when an
economy is doing well,
it's easy to keep an authoritarian
system.
Getting.
Many citizens are pretty much happy to
say,
yeah,
I'll trade a bit of freedom if I get
some welfare,
but Iran has spent too much time without
welfare.
Iranian currency.
There y'all is devaluing every single
day and this has led to a brutal
inflation.
Some non official estimates claim that
Iran will have more than a hundred
percent inflation rate this year.
That means that some prices change on a
daily basis.
Many foods like chicken are starting to
become scarce and there are more and
more people living below the poverty.
Even with the government privatizations.
The economy is a mess.
We're already told you,
you right here on visual politic at the
beginning of the year,
2018 started with massive protests
against the Rouhani,
governments,
and many of those protesters were young
university students.
He wanted a shift in the system,
uh,
shifted to a system that's democratic,
secular,
and liberal.
But the question that,
the real question here is,
is all of this enough to cause regime
change?
Well,
today we're going to answer that
question,
but before we do,
let's take a look back at the history
taurine guard.
In the end.
Nineteen 79,
the Islamic revolution started in Iran.
The supreme leader back then was the
Ayatollah Khomeini,
and he knew that the army might be
transit anymore decades of saving the
shower pleasure.
It was hard for them to change their
loyalties overnight.
This is why in order to avoid acute ta
come and he created his own parallel
army.
This is how the Islamic Revolutionary
Guard was created.
It's a sort of modern day Praetorian God
designed to preserve the Islamic
republican system.
In the beginning,
all of the members were volunteers,
but things changed in the eight.
Hmm.
Back then,
Iran started a war with Iraq and who did
they send to the front?
Of course,
they sent these Praetorian,
see why willing to do anything for their
cause and do you know what,
in times of warfare,
there's always money for weapons.
This is how the Islamic revolution
regard gained a lot more influence and
certainly anymore weaponry and
experience.
By the end of the Iran,
Iraq war,
this Praetorian God already had more
than 130,000 soldiers,
plus many other smaller cause that
dependence
them
today.
This revolution regard hasn't signed
intelligence service parallel to the
government's Ministry of Intelligence
and they can imprison people and
investigate them without us even
reporting to the authorities.
In other words,
they are the cornerstone of the Islamic
revolution,
but then again,
they do have this parallel system and
well,
why are they important?
Well,
the truth is,
as far as the economy goes,
it's hard to create an alternative to
the system.
If you have an elite corp spying on any
would be political activists and yeah,
we really are talking about an elite
core here.
They're perfectly trained for hybrid
warfare.
They fought in many other wars such as
in Syria,
Iraq,
and even in Afghanistan,
and all of the experts say that training
as well as class.
You might be wondering.
I mean,
we talked about weapons.
How do they buy weapons if Iran is so
isolated from the international market?
How on earth is that possible?
Well,
the truth is that for decades,
Ron has had its own weapons
manufacturing industry.
Yep.
You had that right.
They use Chinese and Russian designs,
but the manufacturing is all done in
Iran.
So now of course the question becomes
will they be affected by these economic
sanctions?
I mean,
at the end of the day,
if Iran has no money,
there's got to be able to buy bullets
and weapons.
Right?
Well,
if you are,
the reality is nothing
external pressure and black.
A foreign competitors will most likely
help the Irg see further consolidate
it's grip over Iran's economy.
Ali Elforni,
Arab Gulf states institute in Washington
for better understanding,
a big portion of Iran's economy is in
the revolution regards hands.
They own many statement or police
cleaning oil companies,
refineries and real estate firms.
For example,
51 percent of Iran telecom belongs to
them.
Add to this,
the fact they pay almost no taxes and do
you have completely self sustainable
economics with a parallel army that so
well maintained?
It's hard to have regime change well
bus,
if you've thought this was the only
asset that the ayatollah does have,
well you'd be wrong,
and now you're going to see why
China comes to the rescue.
We've said this many times in this three
video series,
China will keep buying oil from Iran.
They just can't stop doing this.
China needs a lot of oil and for years
Iran has been there six most important
supplier.
We're talking about more than 800,000
barrels that come from Iran every single
day.
With these numbers.
It's really hard to change providers
and.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I know what you're thinking.
Probably right now.
You've probably seen those previous
videos and you're thinking,
well,
America has got that secret weapon
that's going to keep countries from
buying Iranian oil.
As we talked about in the last video,
basically no tanker can dock in a harbor
if it's not covered by an insurance
company in most of the insurance
companies.
Well the European or American.
So now the question comes is how does
China buy oil from Iran with this
problem?
Well,
check this out.
Elusive.
China's shifts to Iranian tankers to
keep oil flowing a mid US sanctions.
Yeah,
you have that right.
Without insurance companies,
Iran will take care of the transport and
bad all of the risk and this.
Well,
this is pretty great for the people
receiving the oil before that have to
worry about maintenance,
but now they're on bays.
They'd have to worry about a ship now
reaching its destination.
Don't worry.
Iran spaying ships things in the.
See something terrible happens again,
Iran pays,
but this is still not the whole story.
Think about it.
If the rest of the world is going to
stop investing in Iran,
what do we have left?
Exactly.
We've just freed up space for China's
money.
Hence news like this
Chinese
from to invest $2,000,000,000 an oil
refinery in Iran.
Yeah.
You heard that right?
China is taking advantage of the void.
Other companies have all act.
In fact,
they are even buying the investments.
Other European companies have nate,
for example,
of this type,
all the French oil company in 2016,
they started building what was meant to
be the biggest gas field on the planet.
Now with trump sanctions,
chances are they're going to have to
retard this projects.
Guests who's ready to buy it.
Well,
that would be China
this summer
in 2018,
the trend of development bank announced
that they will provide more than $15,
billion dollars in loans for all kinds
of things.
Gotcha.
Might
wonder in the grand scheme of things,
is this a lot of money or not so much?
Well,
it has already helped to start building
five brand new hospitals.
And then what about other companies?
Really when I told you that Iran is one
of the biggest car manufacturers in the
region.
Well,
one of the main brands there is cyber.
They've already signed a joint venture
with another Chinese company called
Brilliance,
but this,
this is just the beginning.
Was the most ambitious projects
currently going on from China?
Well,
yeah.
That's the one belt.
One road projects.
That's the new Silk Road that shooting
pain wants to build.
I's Iran as important belt and road pub.
So far they've already started to
renovate several railroads.
The idea is to connect the main Iranian
cities with high speed train so that
they can transport goods and now you
might be wondering,
well,
why is it so important?
Well,
just have a look at this map and Milan.
Imagine a train full of mobile phones
traveling from China going through
Central Asia and then going from Iran to
Turkey.
It looks like the perfect group for
trying to just sell mobile phones.
Dr. Right now,
of course,
this is just one idea.
So far,
Chinese businesses are already facing
many issues in central Asia,
but this is definitely a massive friend
of the video.
The truth is China is starting to invest
heavily in Iran.
Does this mean that Xi Jinping will save
arounds economy?
Of course.
Nice,
but will this be enough for the regime
to survive?
Well,
just maybe,
and this explains why in recent years
the political relations between these
two countries are becoming more and more
fluid.
Ping Holtz talks with President Hassan
Rouhani of Iran.
So now is your time.
Do you really think that trump's
sanctions will help end the ayatollah's
regime?
Well,
please do leave your answers in the
comments section below and if you want
to dive deeper into all of the caveats
of nuclear sanctions,
you can check out the whole series we've
published.
There are two parts previous to this
one.
Also do visit the reconsider media
website there,
the podcast that provided the voices in
this episode that were not mine.
Do don't forget to subscribe to visual
politic.
Click on the bell icon as well so you
don't miss any of our posts and if you
like this video,
give us a thumbs up and as always I'll
see you next time
and if you want to learn more about
politics and hear more of my lovely
voice,
don't forget to checkout.
Reconsider podcast at me.
Consider media.com and we consider it as
a podcast that challenges you to
reconsider your reviews by providing
context,
but we don't do the thinking.